Speaker 1: All right. You may or may not remember
the story I'm about to talk about. This incident
in question happened in September of 2020. There
was an incident where there was BLM, Antifa,
Joe Biden spray painted at a business and all
of the right wing media, even though the entire
thing stunk to high heaven, came out to talk about
how violent the left is and how terrible and and
terroristic Black Lives Matter and Antifa are.
And we have now learned from court documents and
a release from the district of Minnesota,
district attorney of Minnesota's office,
that it was all a hoax. It was all an insurance
hoax. So let's start with the new document from
the U.S. Attorney's Office for Minnesota. Brooklyn
Center man pleads guilty to insurance fraud after
staging a politically motivated arson attack.
Oh, that's pretty interesting. What happened?
According to court documents on September 23rd
of 2020, Dennis Mueller, 30 years old, falsely
reported to law enforcement that someone lit his
camper on fire. Oh, it was a camper. Not a yeah,
not a business. A lit his camper on fire.
And that three unknown males were near the
home when he heard an explosion. Mueller also
reported his garage door was vandalized with
spray painted graffiti, which said Biden
2020 BLM and an Antifa symbol and that his
camper was targeted because it had a Trump 2020
flag on it. The idea was this was a political
incident. In reality, Marla started his own
property on fire and spray painted the graffiti
on his own garage. According to court documents,
Marla submitted multiple insurance claims seeking
coverage for the damage to his garage, camper
vehicles and residence. When the company denied
the claims. He submitted a complaint. Mueller also
created and allowed others to create multiple go
fund me accounts to benefit him and his family.
He submitted more than $300,000 in fraudulent
insurance claims, got 61 K from his insurance
company and 17,000 from donors via go fund me.
He has now pleaded guilty to one count of wire
fraud. Sentencing will happen at a later time.
So how did we find out this was a
hoax? Well, as it says in the release,
it was investigated by the FBI and the Brooklyn
Center. Remember, this is Brooklyn, Minnesota,
Brooklyn Center Police Department. Let's go back
and look at how Ben SHAPIRO and Laura Ingram
talked about this particular incident at the time.
Speaker 6: There's a story out of Minnesota that
began to get some traction today, and it was
very disturbing. And this was a homeowners who
woke up to find that their garage basically was
on fire. And did they really burn down? They had
a Trump they had a Trump flag or poster up and had
been burned. And then Biden 2020 graffiti and the
Antifa symbol. And this this is Minnesota. Nice.
There's a message being sent then by the far left.
And I think people are beginning to see that arson
is behavior, looting, even murder. None of it's
off the table. Right. Well, the fact.
Speaker 1: Is, either way, murder,
what are you talking about?
Speaker 6: And generic statements
about violence and looting being bad are not going
to cut it. We all know that if this were right
wingers were performing this kind of violence,
Joe Biden would be out there on the front lines
proclaiming the right wing ideology was innately
linked to violence and cruelty. But as soon as it
is, left wingers in his coalition are out there
harassing people at restaurants or burning things
down or perhaps shooting police officers,
as we saw in Louisville last night. Well,
then the movement that they are linked to, the
broader ideological movement they are linked to,
he refuses to condemn. It's one thing to condemn
generically violence and looting. I was told,
by the way, when Donald Trump did that
back in Charlottesville, that wasn't
enough. He had to specifically condemn
one specific ideology, which, by the way,
he kind of. He absolutely did, actually. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So it was all a hoax. And the of
course, none of them are following up on it.
It was actually an insurance hoax perpetrated
by an actual Trumpists. Because, remember, even
though the BLM Biden Antifa stuff was fake in the
sense that it was done by the homeowner, the
homeowners trump flag was real. It was really
a Trumpist homeowner. Now, does that mean all
Trumpists are insurance fraudsters? Of course it
doesn't. But look at how the story was leveraged
by Ben SHAPIRO and Laura Ingraham to make a
broader point. In general, leftists are violent,
Antifa is violent, Black Lives Matter is violent,
and they are willing to go even further using
the fraudulent and fake story of the spray paint
to say even murder isn't too much for them. What?
What murder? What are you talking about? What on
earth are you talking about? The real scary part
is that when the Fox News audience sees this,
they start to believe, Well, if the left
is so violent against us, then we can be
violent against them because it's only fair.
Even though the premise is a fraudulent hoax
for which someone has now been convicted. So
you'll never get the correction from them,
obviously. But at least I'm doing what I can to
make sure, you know, the entire thing. They made
a big deal out of it for multiple days back when
it happened. The entire thing was a Trumpist hoax